wenn du einkochen möchtest dann solltest
du dich vorher mit einem wichtigen Thema
beschäftigen mit
butulismus was hat es mit dieser
potentiell tödlichen
Lebensmittelvergiftung auf sich und wie
kann man butulismus sicher und einfach
vermeiden einmal vorweg ich möchte mit
dem Video hier überhaupt keine Panik
verbreiten sondern ich möchte euch die
Sicherheit geben dass ihr selbstbewusst
und entspannt einkochen könnt worauf ihr
Lust habt ohne Angst vor butulismus
haben zu müssen einkochen ist nämlich
eine richtig tolle Methode um ern
Überschüsse haltbar zu machen und ich
koche selber super viel ein und man muss
keine Angst vor dem Einkochen haben man
muss sich nur einmal bevor man loslegt
über das Thema butulismus informieren
und beim Einkochen dann ein paar Dinge
im Hinterkopf behalten ich gebe Kurse
zum haltbarmachchen der Ernte und da
spielt das Einkochen natürlich eine
ziemlich große Rolle und als ich mit dem
Thema butulismus konfrontiert war hatte
ich natürlich selber unfassbar viele
Fragen also habe ich wahnsinnig viel
recherchiert und bei den Fragen wo ich
selber nicht weiter gekommen bin weil
sich die Informationen da draußen
teilweise auch ziemlich doll
widersprechen habe ich mir dann
Lebensmittelchemiker ins Boot geholt
damit wir zusammen Antworten auf die
1000 Fragen finden die ich hatte und in
diesem Video fasse ich alles was ihr
wissen müsst damit ihr mit einem richtig
guten Gefühl sicher einkochen könnt für
euch zusammen da draußen werden leider
immer noch relativ hart der Keks sehr
falsche Informationen verbreitet und
deswegen es es mir ein großes Anliegen
darüber noch mal sachlich auf zuklären
und euch alle wichtigen Infos an die
Hand zu geben ich lese in meinen
Kommentaren z.B immer wieder Dinge wie
das ist ja totaler Quatsch wir haben
immer normal eingekocht und bei uns ist
nie jemand gestorben und ja früher hat
man einfach nicht besser gewusst dass es
sowas wie butulismus gibt und man konnte
früher auch nicht jeden Todesfall
korrekt zuordnen außerdem ist butulismus
super selten und deswegen ist es auch
kein Wunder dass sehr viele Leute in
Anführungszeichen normal einkochen und
ih bisher nichts passiert ist aber es
gibt immer noch Todesfälle auch in
Deutschland und wenn man erkrankt dann
hat man eine sehr hohe
Sterblichkeitsrate die bei unbehandelten
Fällen bei ungefähr 70% liegt falls eins
deiner Gläser befallen ist reichen schon
kleine Mengen aus um butulismus
auszulösen es ist also wichtig dass man
das ganze ernst nimmt auch wenn es
natürlich super selten vorkommt und wenn
man das im Hinterkopf hat ist es einfach
kein schönes Gefühl das eingekochte zu
essen oder der eigenen Familie
aufzutischen also lasst uns das Thema
einfach sachlich ernst nehmen und uns
den Spaß am einkochen bewahren und am
allerbesten schmeckt's doch wenn man
weiß dass man alles richtig gemacht hat
also was zum Teufel ist eigentlich
butulismus butulismus entsteht durch
dieses kleine kärchen das ist ein
Bakterium mit dem wunderschönen Namen
klostridium butulinum wie kann es sein
dass von diesem winzigen kärchen so eine
große Gefahr ausgeht also das Bakterium
lebt im Boden und ist erstmal überall
auch auf frischem Gemüse oder Fleisch
und da verursacht es uns Menschen
erstmal absolut gar keine Probleme erst
wenn es in unsere Einkochgläser wandert
wird es kritisch aber wieso erstmal
denkt man sich ja dass der Sinn des
Einkochens darin besteht durch Hitze
alle Bakterien abzutöten aber
glostridium butotulinum kennt einen
Zaubertrick vielleicht habt ihr ja schon
mal von bakteriensporen gehört das
Bakterium kann sich in eine Spore
umwandeln deren harte Hülle
ausgesprochen resistent ist gegenüber
Säure Kälte oder Hitze jetzt mal so ein
bisschen basic physic wenn wir Wasser in
einen Topf geben und es erhitzen kocht
es egal wie viel Hitze wir hinzugeben
rein physikalisch bei maximal 100°. das
reicht aber nicht aus um den butulinum
Spuren den Gar aus zuumachchen die
Bakterien sterben bei 100° ab aber die
Spuren nicht und wenn man jetzt
beispielsweise Bohnen in einem ganz
normalen wasserbadtopf einkocht dann
können die Sporen im Glas überleben und
in dem Glas fühlen die sich dann richtig
wohl die lieben nämlich zwei Dinge
Sauerstoffabschluss und Wärme und beides
ist beim Einkochen gegeben aus diesen
Spuren können dann im einkochglas wieder
vollständige klostridium butotulinum
Bakterien auskeimen und die produzieren
unter Sauerstoffabschluss im
eininkochglas das Gift das letztendlich
die Lebensmittelvergiftung auslöst wenn
wir das eingekochte dann essen das Gift
nennt sich übrigens
butulinumtoxin aber wie können wir das
jetzt verhindern da gibt drei
Möglichkeiten du denkst das hier ist nur
ein Topf nee das ist kein normaler Topf
sondern das hier ist der Schlüssel um
butulismus sicher einzukochen wieso was
kann der druckeinkochtöpfe wie dieser
hier erreichen Temperaturen die in einem
normalen Topf nicht möglich sind und die
sowohl die Bakterien als auch die fiesen
kleinen Sporen abtöten damit bist du
also auf der sicheren Seite allerdings
hat der Topf auch einen stolzen
Anschaffungspreis da musst du also
abwägen ob du du dir so einen
druckeinkochtopf gönnen willst oder ob
du es mit einer der anderen Optionen
probierst ich verdiene übrigens keinen
Cent daran dass ich euch diesen Topf
hier vorstelle für alle die das wissen
wollen der Topf ist von der Firma presto
aber wie gesagt ich sag das einfach nur
weil ich denke dass bei euch die Frage
aufkommt und nicht weil ich damit
irgendwas verdiene wichtig wenn du mit
einem druckeinkochtopf einkochst ist
dass du dich immer eins zu eins an die
vorgegebene Zeit und den vorgegebenen
Druck aus deinem Rezept hältst die sind
nämlich je nach dembens mititte
unterschiedlich und um die Spuren sicher
abtüten zu können braucht es immer das
Zusammenspiel aus der richtigen Zeit und
der richtigen Temperatur und die
Temperatur erreichen wir über den
richtigen Druck also achte darauf dass
du immer nur sichere Rezepte verwendest
die findet man z.B kostenlos bei der
USDA und in meinem Onlinekurs Obst und
Gemüse haltbar machen haben wir auch
richtig viele leckere und sichere
Rezepte für euch zusammengestellt aber
was für Optionen hat man wenn man sich
keinen druckeinkochtopf zulegen möchte
das butulinumtoxin also das Gift das
sich im Falle der Fälle in deinen
Gläsern gebildet hat ist ein Eiweiß und
das ist nicht besonders hitzebeständig
wenn du die Gläser nicht unter Druck
eingekocht hast kannst du den Inhalt vor
dem Essen sprudelnd aufkochen du hast
also z.B einen richtig leckeren Eintopf
eingekocht aber da wusstest du noch
nichts vom butulismus und der steht
jetzt bei dir im Schrank und du fragst
Dich muss ich das jetzt wegwerfen nee
das musst du nicht wegwerfen du musst
das nur bevor du das isst einmal richtig
durcherhitzen man hat da so Untersuchung
gemacht und dabei rausgefunden dass das
Lebensmittel aus dem einkochglas für
mindestens 3 Minuten auf 80° erhitzt
werden muss du gibst also den Inhalt
deines einkochglases in einen Topf und
um diese 80° Kerntemperatur für 3
Minuten zu erreichen musst du dein
Eingekochtes ungefähr 8 bis 11 Minuten
lang so erhitzen dass es sprudelnd kocht
dann kannst du das eingekochte
bedenkenlos essen weil sich das Gift
eben denaturiert hat falls da Gift in
deinem Glas enthalten sein sollte es es
gibt aber auch noch eine Möglichkeit wie
man ohne druckinkochtopf von vorne rein
verhindern kann dass sich butulismus im
einkochglas bilden kann das ganze nennt
sich
tyündalisation was ist das das ist im
Prinzip doppeltes einkochen bzw
eigentlich dreimaliges einkochen dabei
kochst du deine Lebensmittel ganz normal
im Wasserbad ein die Bakterien sterben
ab und die Spuren Keimen durch den
Sauerstoffabschluss und die Wärme im
Glas aus exakt 24 Stunden später kochst
du das ganze dann noch mal ein bei der
gleichen Temperatur und Zeit und dann
werden die ausgekimten Sporen die jetzt
gar nicht mehr so hitzeresistent sind
abgetötet weil man dabei aber manchmal
nicht alle Sporen erwischt wartet man
dann noch mal 24 Stunden und wiederholt
das Ganze noch mal ein drittes Mal ihr
merkt schon das ganze ist ziemlich
aufwendig aber ich wollte euch die
Methode auf jeden Fall nicht
vorenthalten weil das ganze genauso
sicher ist wie das Einkochen im
druckeinkochtopf und be den Buchen hier
dafür nicht braucht die Gefahr dass sich
but Ismus in einem einkochglas
entwickelt besteht übrigens längst nicht
bei allen Lebensmitteln die allermeisten
könnt ihr sogar einfach gefahrlos
weiterhin im Wasserbad einkochen und wie
man da unterscheidet also wo man
aufpassen muss und wo nicht und woran
das liegt das erkläre ich euch jetzt
kostridium botulinum ist ein
säureempfindliches Bakterium das
bedeutet dass z.B alle Obstarten außer
der Banane absolut bedenkenlos im
Wasserbad eingekocht werden können weil
der pHWert so niedrig ist dass er diese
kleinen kärchen sowieso abtötet
butulismus tritt also nur bei säurearmen
Lebensmitteln wie Fleisch oder Gemüse
auf Marmelade saure Gurken in Essig
eingelegtes Gemüse kompot und Koh könnt
ihr also ohne einen Gedanken an
butulismus sicher einkochen Fleisch aber
nicht und z.B auch keinen Eintopf oder
keine Karotten Erbsen und so weiter also
alles was nicht sauer ist da muss man
auf das butulismus Thema achten und eine
der drei Möglichkeiten verwenden ein
paar von euch werden sich wahrscheinlich
denken aber mein Backofen erreicht ja
Temperaturen von über 100° kann ich die
Gläser nicht einfach da reinstellen da
muss ich euch leider enttäuschen denn
auch im Backofen kann der Inhalt eurer
Gläser rein physikalisch nicht heißer
als bei 100° kochen aber riecht man das
nicht geht nicht irgendwie der Deckel
auf wenn das ganze schlecht wird nicht
unbedingt es gibt nämlich verschiedene
butulinumstämme manche der Bakterien
bilden Gase s dass die einkoch Laser ihr
Vakuum verlieren und man es an dem
Deckel sehen kann das ist übrigens immer
ein Zeichen dafür dass man das Glas
entsorgen sollte andere butulinumstämme
bilden aber keine Gase und können sich
dadurch komplett unbemerkt im
einkochglas vermehren nur weil der
Deckel fest auf dem Glas sitzt heißt das
also leider nicht dass sich kein
butulinum Toxin in dem eingekochten
gebildet hat wenn ihr Lust habt mehr zum
Thema haltbar machen zu lernen dann
schaut mal da drüben vorbei da kommt ihr
zu meiner macht deine Ernte haltbar
Challenge das kostet euch kein Geld und
da findet ihr sowohl Anleitung als auch
Rezepte zum Einkochen zum fermentieren
zum Dörren und auch eine richtig tolle
Community also seid gerne mit dabei
ansonsten geht raus macht die Welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns im
nächsten Video wieder macht's
gut